bonjour à tous c'est le moment de cesser
toutes vos activités installez-vous bien
confortablement nous sommes là avec nos
équipes d'experts et de commissaires
priseur le collectif écologiste les
soulèvements de la Terre a été dissout
ce matin en conseil des ministres
l'annonce en a été faite par le Ministre
de l'Intérieur Gérald de Darmanin qui
portait cette demande le gouvernement se
justifie en parlant de sabotage de
dégradation matérielle et de violence à
mettre à l'actif de ce groupe à gauche
des voix se sont élevées pour défendre
ce mouvement des écologistes marines
Tondelier ou Sandrine Rousseau à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
étaient considérés comme des terroristes
et maintenant c'est soulevant de la
terre qui considérait de la même manière
c'est-à-dire que la résistance aux nazis
pour elle il y a un signe d'égalité avec
soulèvement de la terre non mais on est
dans l'indignité on est dans la
comparaison entre des choses qui n'ont
aucun rapport le
on y comprend rien pas ta caisse pas ta
caisse j'avais des bons résultats en
piano ah oui et vous du pipeau
essentiellement oui mais bon voilà
oui non mais la réponse
à la télévision
elle le prend bien comme vous limitez ou
pas ma mère oui
en Grèce alors ma maman
donc le micro je l'enlève parce que j'ai
plus envie de parler j'ai plus rien à
dire je suis fatigué j'ai la tête comme
ça ça me gave je veux rentrer chez moi
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de votre fils
madame le pire
ou pas
[Rires]
je vous l'ai dit
il travaille trop
douce 2020 mais ça c'est parce que c'est
les restos du cœur qui nous ont donné
vous ajoutez du coeur parce qu'on a plus
d'argent
on a tellement de dettes qu'on s'en sort
plus
il y en avait du beau monde hier soir à
Paris sur le pont Neuf théâtre du
premier défilé du nouveau styliste de
Louis Vuitton Pharrell Williams en cette
semaine de la mode masculine il est
habillé ces mannequins en tenue
camouflage je chique devant 1750 invités
parmi lesquelles un tapis de star allant
de Rihanna beyoncé et Jay-Z en passant
par Leonardo DiCaprio la trisen Daya le
basketteur LeBron James ou encore le
pilote automobile Lewis Hamilton
du corps pour manger pour nous à titre
perso soit même pas manger sur la
société on paye tout notre poche pour la
société tout tout puisque la banque elle
nous rejette tout
et comment tu achètes la marchandise
pour l'instant
c'est une soirée incroyable et c'est
géniale de pouvoir y participer merci
merci Louis Vuitton vous êtes en direct
un artiste
un moment il était sur Europe 1 et il
savait que je l'aime pas trop il me l'a
dit en direct à la radio et ça me fait
monter en estime ah oui je trouve ça
bien
courageux
[Rires]
oui parce que
je l'ai connu avant qu'il fait la
réussite qu'il fait et c'est le
président Joe Biden qui a mis le feu aux
poudres en affirmant que son homologue
chinois chez inping appartenait je cite
à la catégorie dictateur Pékin c'est
aussitôt indigné
et j'aime pas trop qu'on me parle aux
gens je parle pas de ce même d'ailleurs
chroniqueuse mais
il parle aux gens comme si nous prend
pour des enfants ça m'embête un peu
ouais il me rend un peu en chemise et
comme mon père était Juifs c'est
peut-être oui
franchement j'ai un sentiment de peur
qui me gagne petit à petit ça me glace
le sang vraiment bien terminé
ça m'a fait penser à notre ingénieur
Sylvain baron qui connaît bien le
dossier Sylvain vous êtes là un élément
PVC quoi j'ai dit on va sur du dur quoi
il est en train de parler à une femme si
ça se trouve il est tout nu dans une
chambre d'hôtel
qui va se passer tu vas voir on va aller
sur du dur tu vas me comprendre c'est
signe devenu accro aux pavot vous savez
le pavot ça ressemble à un coquelicot
c'est la plante qui contient
naturellement de de l'opium qu'on peut
extraire pour fabriquer de la morphine
ou de l'héroïne donc de la drogue et ce
groupe de signes est devenu complètement
accro à ses coquelicots dans un champ ça
se passe en Slovaquie c'est la radio
suisse qui raconte cette histoire assez
incroyable de son signe devenu toxico
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup ce morceau à tout le
monde
on va biologiste sur place à raconter
que ces signes rampaient dans le champ
incapable de voler paralysé par les
effets déshydratés ils ont perdu
beaucoup de fois on a des dizaines
d'oiseaux qui sont morts c'est terrible
et une équipe de sauveteurs ont
entrepris d’aller les secourir et de les
envoyer en cure exactement
on estime qu'il ne leur reste qu'une
vingtaine d'heures d'oxygène mais un
mince espoir subsiste des avions P3
Canadiens ont détecté des bruits
sous-marins dans la zone de recherche en
conséquence les opérations des robots
sous-marins ont été déplacés afin
d'essayer d'explorer l'origine des
bruits ces recherches n'ont pas donné de
résultats concluants mais elle se
poursuivent d'après une note du
gouvernement américain cité par CNN il
pourrait s'agir de connuments entendu à
intervalles réguliers de 30 minutes mais
c'est la fin d'une aventure incroyable
très belle de six ans pour moi à la
matinale de France Info et en fait je
voulais juste vous dire que c'était une
aventure exceptionnelle pour pour une
raison
c'est ces gens
professionnels et humainement sont des
gens formidables et c'est un bonheur de
se lever tous les jours à 2h du matin
pour les retrouver